hey this is Moshe kasher and Natasha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love advice to
strangers so that's what we did we
packed up the car hit the road and
spread the love yes come on better my
boots look yeah awesome boot cleaning
solution today here in Portland wait
most you should do that thing where I'm
like no woman jerks off two feet you're
trying to work on a joke about that like
there's no woman who's like needs to
come on someone's mailgram and repeat
although women do have fetishes not feet
no no there any female foot fetishes
finish it no way yeah I bet you there's
zero in the world
this ticket
once I get $15 and a beer so on
I heard you have a ticket for sale you
my husband got sick he do you need the
tacos Obama for dinner
probably vomiting right now
hi is this Kelly
hey Kelly its Moshe kasher Natasha
Leggero
hi we're really embarrassed your wife's
trying to sell your ticket our show yeah
we were wondering if you could maybe we
know you're not feeling well but we were
wondering if you could maybe talk her
out of doing this so the host of a
relationship expertise show mr. Greg
Behrendt Greg if you want to come out so
we've been married for seven years
Christy once wore jing COEs Kinkos are a
style of pant originally actually
started by a family called the Gingka
family in Florence the progenitor of
Salvatori Jenko first created Harlequin
pants and clown pants for the Opera and
then he actually came over to America
where his son carried on the family loom
finally in 1991 when Frankie bones and
some other sick DJ's start at
the rave scene this is a pretty happy
couple if that's the worst problem they
have all right give them a round of
applause with a real real come on up
come on up okay so willow what is your
main problem with Danny that you'd like
to discuss and then he can say his with
you yeah
yes yeah the problem I think is me the
problem is sometimes like this morning
she was putting on some shorts dude and
I was like oh are you gonna wear those
cuz I'd rather you didn't there's like I
stopped telling me that I look good
because it makes me feel bad and I'm
like I'm scared that you're gonna
go out without me and get rid oh this
has been a great comedy show I've seen
you at the Hawthorne you're really gonna
come yeah we're the comedian's we just
got married and we're very famous
household names so it's not the same
problem that they had where he doesn't
like her is her Z pant what are they
called
gingka Kinkos but your problem is you
want her to wear some zinc O's you want
your struggling with some some real
issues some real self-esteem stuff
because that's not about her that's
about the sadness inside of you man
you're just afraid you're gonna lose our
period so that means you don't feel good
enough about yourself in the
relationship sorry I'm great at this
I just I'm great at what do you
think I don't even want to be I wanted
to be in a band
I like to play devil's advocate mm-hmm I
think Willow scoot over yeah I feel like
willow could duel maybe just a little
bit better job of letting Danny know how
how sexy is and how how how manly he is
and how attracted to him you are and he
needs to be a little more confident and
and realized that not every every man is
as a creep like you and and that your
love is good enough beautiful you guys
commit to it absolutely I want to help
someone else he's so good at oh he is
good at he maybe we should have him to
us I don't know I don't wanna go down
that path oh no no no I like you guys I
want to stay friends
yeah oh you want me to say what my
problem is it go for it all right he
isn't real messy like when he drop
something he told me once his instinct
is to run away from it so that's like a
whole house do you want stuff thank you
I'm gonna handle that way if you ever
want to that's the only problem
like the little the little tiny is
there just seeds and they grow trust me
so like hear that and start pegging your
up I'm telling you it'll wreck it
that's dumbest thing you'll be like
because you'll be are barely like why is
that if in a relationship that's a easy
compromise if you really love the person
you'll do the thing they want you to do
and not the thing you prefer to do that
makes sense
my turn no I think we're done
one thing that I don't like is that that
basically like she is not faithful to me
I guess you know you're gonna have to
get over that people have their own
lives and they gotta be who they are you
know pick up your let her go she
feels like it's gonna save your marriage
I swear to god you guys thank you so
much for coming out how old are you I'm
whoo 19 how they developer you and
you're 19